okay manchmal passiert es auch mir ich
gehe dem einen oder anderen gast an die
gurgel dieses mal erwischte supreme
reloaded die leute halten sich für die
sympathischen youtuber naja nicht ganz
seid gespannt und guckt das fragen lotto
mit ganz ganz gemein fragen
sorgen würde dass fragen lotto die roten
sind gemeinden fragen gemeine frage die
grünen die ziehen oder mit mir kannste
ja wir können den
lassen
wir mal wie
kann der ganzen anderen leute die roten
fragen als erstes
wollt ihr nicht was vernünftiges lernen
was ist daran nicht vernünftig
ich meine seinen traum zu verfolgen
das ist ja das vernünftigste man was man
machen kann und wenn einem die
gelegenheit gegeben wird das was einem
spaß macht also sein hobby zum beruf
machen warum sollte man das nicht
annehmen dass es daran nicht vernünftig
das verstehe ich nicht
ich finde das perfekt beantwortet wir
haben immer dass die lebensweisheit wenn
alles schief geht mit 30 haben was links
ins probiert und dann können wir immer
noch was normales machen
bachelor tralala wir waren ja alle
studieren aber aber so unvernünftig wird
wie wir scheinen jetzt nicht mehr
zerrissen geschmissen also ich finde
unseren weg viel vernünftiger weil
wir haben ja halt studiert auch an einer
schauspielschule
sie sind halt auch in die richtung
gegangen und wir haben da
nichts gelernt und
wir wussten da irgendwie schon das
meiste und für wir mussten da im monat
so viel geld verprassen dass wir da halt
zur schule gehen dürfen und für wissen
was du bereits jetzt geld auszugeben das
ist ja wohl unvernünftig ja gut das muss
man ja sagen dass es nicht immer so ne
also es ist nicht immer wenn du
studierst weißt du das schon das ist ja
nicht so aber ich sehe es genauso was
das ist nicht so ich sehe das nicht als
unvernünftig natürlich könnten wir jetzt
was ist vernünftigen lehre als schreiner
oder so aber ich glaube das wäre nicht
so optimal bei uns sie mal was grün ist
jetzt hier
ich glaube sind da solche hammer fragen
auch irgendwie wenigstens so
haben wir fragen was wäre der hammer
frage können wir keine frage also ihr
könnt ihr selber mal überlegen waren ich
kriege meine frage wäre ja woher nehmt
ihr eure kreativität
jetzt wahrscheinlich antwortet gleich
irgendwie proben
meist so haben sie ja das ist echt
harmlos ist ja auch eine grüne also die
haare aus dem alltag eigentlich will
muss viel erleben und kreativ zu sein
kranke sachen gucken erleben weil sie
nicht dann kommt uns in einer sekunde
eine idee für ein komplettes video
jetzt nimrod hier nur rot rot rot sind
wir alle nehmen
doch schluss machen
die ja wie zwei deutsche und ein
türkisches youtube
ein türkischer youtube ziehen nach köln
das hatten wir doch schon mal
nicht also weiter tina darauf spielt da
was st doch das ist doch kein türke oder
frauen haben wir gewusst
also nein natürliche salzburg yanar und
es gab auch schon mal es gibt alles
mehrfach froh ist auch nicht aber wir
haben mit politik geredet
und halt unsere vergangenheit so
verglichen und das ist so
quasi so ein spiegelbild von uns und das
ist so richtig krass die haben sich auch
so in demselben alter um den dreh so
kennen gelernt wie wir da haben wir auch
so so richtig erstaunt was so ein zufall
kann es doch nicht geben dazu noch das
tier sei quasi die baltic ist aus dem
noch bis 13
herter
was
ja warte ich will meine rote hier
keine eigenen ideen ihr kopiert doch von
smash wir wussten so halb dass das kommt
ich denke mal jeder erstens sind die
riesige smos fans ja und vielleicht wenn
man dann denkt ja was könnte man machen
denkt man so habe überdies muss das
machen ok und vielleicht ist es dann
daher so ähnlich viel aber ich denke mal
es gab alles schon mal
es gab alles bevor irgendwer gemacht hat
irgendwer vor die interviews gemacht
dann bist du jetzt kein nachmacher mit
interviews das gibt es aber kaum einer
hat mich ist die lage ja das stimmt aber
sicherlich hat macht es muss auch sachen
die vorher gemacht hat von daher finde
ich das ein bisschen
ich glaube herr spielt auch auf
unsere pforten
da an diese
schleudergang oder irgendwie sowas und
ich meine das ist ein stilmittel und
stilmittel darf er jeder frei verwenden
ich finde das absolut nicht
nachvollziehen dass sich leute über
sowas aufregen weil es ich meine wir
machen jetzt nicht genau dasselbe wie es
muss oder wie
was gibt es noch für leute es gibt jene
arena inspiriert sich irgendwo das ist
völliger schwachsinn was sich da nicht
ganz verstehe ich sage mal es wäre 121
von swatch oder von irgendwem kopiert
eins zu eins aber es ist gut also man
lacht dabei wo ist dann das problem also
das problem hat wenn also wenn jemand
wirklich ein sketch einzel 1 kopiert ja
okay sagt ja okay sagen wir mal dann hat
er an koblenz sagt mir ich sagen wenn
man kopiert den sie die lieder aber man
wenn man die kacke guckt dann macht man
so richtig aus dem herz raus wie so sagt
man ein höchst nachgemachte das ist ja
auch immer die frage was ist die grenze
man kann die sache da ist einer komisch
der ist auch komischer der kopierten wir
das auch komisch ja genau aber ihr habt
euch ein bisschen getroffen jetzt geht's
los
nein nicht wirklich wann macht ihr mal
lustige
wir waren immer unlustig und lehrer
bleiben das habe man darauf antworten
einmal vernünftige fragen
was ist das für eine frage ich meinen
die meisten leute finden unsere videos
lustig wenn es jetzt eine einzige person
jetzt nicht lustig findet ja
aufgeschlossener so oft wenn video
fertig ist und ich mir das angucken
denke ich so mahnt die größte chance die
sich finde es so viele videos von uns so
unlustig und dann denke ich oh [__] das
kann man nicht hochladen das audi kacke
aber das schlägt dann trotzdem wir ganz
gut ein wie eine bombe also macht ihr
euch dann wirklich mal so
ich habe schon gar nicht ich habe also
es wurde schon öfter gesagt ja das
können wir nicht hochladen wir müssen
was anderes drehen und dann trotzdem
gemacht und das war gegen eine mega ab
also keine ahnung
also ist geschmack ist schwierig zu
entscheiden und es ist noch eine rote
frage da ja immer noch
das mit dem dann saison parodien solltet
ihr lieber lassen ohren krebs
vorprogrammiert
ja das hat sicherlich zwei gründe der
erste ist wir können nicht möglich
singen und wir wollten nicht so hat mit
autotune daran und unser migros halt
ultra müll
ja wir werden sicherlich eine rückwand
parodien machen aber dann an dem sound
arbeiten und dann sollte das nicht so
unerträglich sein oder
der zeppelin hat eine starre konstanze
heis liga und er hat keine starken
warum habt ihr eigentlich keine ahnung
von irgendwas
stolpern so durchs
grüne zum abschluss dann kommt
warum kommt ihr sodann das auf die frage
an kommt ihr müsst ihr nicht mehr
stellen
warum kommt ihr sowieso ansteht warum
kommen hier gut so gut an ja
nein also die frage ist aus unserer
sicht zu beantworten wir sagen jetzt
nicht dass wir gut ankommen oder ja
keine ahnung
wenn man irgendetwas positives dorf
antwortet er wirkt nun gleich so
selbstverliebt wir haben halt alles so
raus wie wir sind wir was denken fertig
und wenn es ankommt dann jahren nicht da
nicht aber kommt er dann ja
wahrscheinlich genau deswegen wir machen
das einfach so wie wir denken und wir
hatten auch schon viele videos wo was
irgendwie so halbwegs daneben liegen
aber wir machen weiter vielleicht sagen
ich habe auch von vielen leuten gehört
dass wir die einzigen youtuber sind die
als menschen auch noch voll in ordnung
sind weil ich habe von das stimmt das
mit den meisten anderen nicht so nein
also dafür alles an und reiste dann von
klienten wieder sagen
ich könnte den canale ein tier sein
wirklich die besten ihr seid die ein
hallo namen so ist das ja gar nicht
gemeint habe ich dass wir statt ich
find ich für andere auch total
sympathisch aber
wenn die das halt so sagen
keine ahnung
heute sind schleimer
da sind wir also ja gut vergessen wir
dass
keine ahnung warum wir so gut ankommen
werde ich freue mich ja auch immer wenn
die leute einen super finden das macht
ja auch spaß ist auch super und
ich weiß ihr seid ja auch relativ simpel
so jetzt den kameras geht aus
und noch mehr fragen lotto videos gibt
es natürlich auch clixoom mit bekannten
youtube zum beispiel mit alexei becks
ihn der erklärt oder den tipp gibt wie
man seine zähne nicht zerstört und das
anlegen wenn er das unbedingt erfahren
wollt und weiter verraten oder sinnieren
darüber wer von ihnen der süßeste ist
das erfahrt ihr in fragen oder mittäter
das oder das könnte jetzt aussehen und
ansonsten bist dran dann ein bis dann
bleibt dran genauso